[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
u Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
Hoy les Hablamos de una realidad
desconocida y subestimada pero muy grave
decenas de mujeres ancianas han sido
violadas o agredidas sexualmente en
residencias en Francia se trata de
personas muy vulnerables que a menudo
por sus patologías no pueden denunciar
en muchos casos la dirección de esos
centros ha intentado disimular estas
agresiones así lo revelan dos
periodistas en un reportaje de
investigación publicado en el sitio web
francés mediapax o feetwoodball y Leyla
miñano que son integrantes de Los
colectivos yuprés y de investing europe
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros y bienvenidas
bueno Sofi Cómo se enteran de que existe
esta realidad y fue fácil acceder a las
fuentes Pues el año pasado hemos
trabajado sobre las residencias de
mayores del grupo herpea por
Y a esta ocasión hemos visto artículos
en la prensa local y Nacional sobre
mujeres que han sido agredidas y
violadas
y sabíamos que fueron
maltratos en general en esos residencias
pero la problemática de las violaciones
en esas residencias no había ciudad
investigada ya O sea que es algo nuevo
no Esa esa investigación
leylandan bastante en el caso de Denisse
93 años
atacada y violada por una persona
externa a la residencia para ancianos en
la que estaba ingresada un caso que nos
lleva a hablar de varias cosas no por un
lado la falta de seguridad no que puede
haber en estos centros Y cómo puede ser
que alguien externo
un centro así pueda entrar en la
residencia si no es un familiar o un
empleado la primera razón
Es la falta de empleado no hay nadie
para controlar quién entra y quién sale
ese fenómeno Es nacional en todas las
residencias hoy en día en Francia en las
privadas en las públicas hay esta falta
de empleado y eso termina con maltratos
de ancianas y a veces con escenas
violadas en el caso de Denisse además se
intentó tapar esa agresión creo que
intentaron hacer pasar la agresión como
si se hubiera caído de las escaleras no
porque la encontraron por el suelo bueno
en fin algo Bastante feo no digamos de
parte de silla bueno es súper grave que
la violación y encima el centro que está
ahí como para cuidarte y protegerte
intenta tapar el caso a la familia
varios casos hemos notado Que las
direcciones de las residencias
intentaron tapar esos casos y en el caso
de Denise es lo que denuncia ha
denunciado la familia porque pensamos
que las direcciones tienen que la
responsabilidad de la residencia está
asociada y teman que otras familias
decidan de poder sus abuelas en otras
residencias y
es un manera de proteger su imagen y su
trabajo y son las mujeres vulnerables
que sufren más de eso en muchos
agresores son trabajadores de los
centros
incluso hay casos en los que ya han
cometido crímenes anteriormente y han
violado anteriormente antes de entrar a
trabajar en esa residencia y gente que
ha cometido este tipo de crímenes
normalmente o sea en teoría no puede
trabajar en este tipo de
establecimientos que está fallando en el
sistema
otra vez el falta de personal de
empleado es decir que cuando los
directores tienen que verificar los
antecedentes penales de los empleados
eso es una obligación por ley no lo
hacen porque no hay no tienen
suficientemente suficiente empleado y
además de eso las agencias regionales de
salud que tienen que controlar estas
residencias controla los papeles de los
empleados no lo hacen tampoco así que a
cada punto de la cadena de
responsabilidad no se hace el trabajo y
eso termina con las violaciones que
hemos visto en nuestra investigación
Sofi los victimarios eligen a víctimas
vulnerables en el caso de los ancianos
son una presa fácil así además titula no
este reportaje de investigación
y eso es lo que quieren también destacar
mucho en este en este trabajo porque
muchas de estas personas tienen salud
muy muy delicada muy frágil muy
deteriorada y ni siquiera pueden hablar
de esas violaciones algunas tienen
Alzheimer incluso algunas no recuerdan
así lo destacan a ustedes en el
reportaje lo que les ha pasado es muy
complicado detectar este tipo de
violaciones
si es muy complicado porque
[Música]
lo que concluyen expertos como
criminólogos psicólogos o asociaciones
es que están mujeres están silenciadas
por su estado de salud
y no por no pueden recordar por algunas
de ellas y además cuando hay un juicio
en la mayoría de los casos esas víctimas
no pueden testimoniar porque
están demasiado psicológicamente frágil
para hablar o está en muerte
Hay muertes en el caso de Denis la
superviviente se dejó morir y morir
antes del juicio Cómo se detectó el caso
de Denisse Cómo cómo se supo que que la
habían violado
como se supo es decir que
fue como un se supo porque le habían
hecho como una
fue el médico no la médica que detectó
eso porque si no nadie se sabría
enterado no pero era muy difícil de
tapar este caso porque la anciana Denis
fue muy maltratado en su en su cuerpo
había varias golpes golpe y todos y
cuando el médico
viene a examinarla no y su el examen
si no hay o sea puede ser que haya
muchos casos no y que no que no que no
se sepan no esta investigación Leila la
han hecho aquí en Francia pero no sé si
tienen noticia de que este fenómeno
también se produce fuera por lo que
sabemos No hay ninguna otra
investigación periodística sobre este
tema en Francia en Europa puede ser
por otra parte sí pero no hemos leído
nada hemos solamente visto este trabajo
extraordinario del criminólogo
y lo hemos entrevistado a varias veces
en el artículo y pero por ninguna parte
este tema está tratado
así que esperemos que eso cambie
el Sophie este trabajo de investigación
Es verdad que hiela la sangre al
principio yo hablaba de decenas de casos
pero un centenar de han llegado a los
tribunales el gobierno reconoce que el
número de casos podría ser monstruoso
esa es la palabra que utiliza el término
que utilizan estamos ante la punta del
iceberg
pienso que sí porque por ejemplo los que
nos dice abogado es que esas personas
vulnerables
no pueden defenderse por sí mismas Y que
cuando los familiares no están detrás
como en el caso de Denis No pasa nada lo
que avanzamos es que hay más casos puede
ser que hay mujeres que no han hablado a
su familia o familias que no pudieran
detectar a los niños de ese coro y en
nuestra investigación hay solamente
casos con denuncia judicial pues
naturalmente podemos suponer que hay
muchos más casos que no lleguen hasta
los tribunales como de manera general
además durante asexual están sub
notificadas y ahí en este caso tenemos
que Añadir que las víctimas tienen más
dificultades a hablar ha habido muchas
condenas Leila
en nuestra opinión no tanta pero lo que
fue una sorpresa para nosotras es que
las condenas cuando ocurren son muy muy
fuerte
los jueces condenas a la cárcel ocho
diez
a veces 12 años de cárcel Lo que jamás
ocurren en el caso de violación más
clásica se puede usar esta palabra
por los jueces el hecho de violar a una
persona vulnerable es considerada como
una circunstancia agravada por eso la
agravante para por eso las penas están
severas cuando ocurren después de
publicar este reportaje de investigación
fue en diciembre el Ministerio de la
solidaridad francés anunció que pondría
a principios de este año un dispositivo
de acción en la residencia es para
proteger a las ancianas de este tipo de
agresiones tienen noticias se ha hecho
algo se ha avanzado
Pues el Ministerio de la solidaridad ha
prometido un plan de acción pero es con
un apartado sobre mujeres especialmente
vulnerables pero no se enfoque en
violencia sexual y a pesar de la
multitud de aletas recibidas al nivel
regional o nacional nunca se ha puesto
en marcha un verdadero plan o va de con
nacional dedicado a denunciar y prevenir
las violencias sexuales en residencias
de mayores pues
una falta de
plan una falta de plan y tal vez de
voluntad del gobierno no sé si de medios
en esta investigación Leyla bueno esta
investigación se inscribe en una serie
de trabajos que se han publicado
recientemente y que revelan malos tratos
no en esta residencias de ancianos malos
tratos generalizados
cuidado insuficiente de las personas que
están ingresadas estamos en lugares de
no derecho
hace varios meses que trabajábamos con
su ya sobre las condiciones en las
residencias estamos cada vez más chocada
de la crueldad en que las los ancianos
les han dejados en estas residencias y
más que todo de la impunidad de estos
maltratos cada vez más maltrato pero una
impunidad de los directores de los que
tienen la responsabilidad de acoger a
todos estos ancianos y
el estado
ha sido
interpelado por este por el periodista
Víctor también para los varios
investigaciones pero la reacción no
ocurre es decir que no fuerza a los
residencia a emplear más gente no
aumenta los controles en las
es decir que a veces estamos obligados
de concluir que las los ancianos y los
ancianas están ciudadanos de segundo
Bueno muchísimas gracias Sofi fútbol y
Leila miñano del colectivo
yuprés por haber venido hasta nuestros
estudios y que sepan que esta
investigación se puede leer en español
en el sitio web infolibre Y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rc mundo.com y
France 24.com Hasta pronto amigos
[Música]